[Music]
groaning so much oh man they're sweet
and bad for you we didn't have a lot of
these these were always like real treats
for my childhood I remember the really
gushers I love to Lunchables I just know
I was going loco over those things I go
to the grocery store it was the holy
sanctuary of goodies that your mom never
gives you I would have to force my
parents to buy them okay I get that look
so cool on TV and my friends have it so
I want it if you don't have what is it
the ding the dingos the ding-a-lings
dangling dunkaroos victory if you don't
got a dunkaroo in your lunchbox no one
loves me this is such a benefice dead
now in Hanover is my life but I rarely
had these I love these things they're so
fun I'm going to be watching cartoons
and to meet commercials for my country's
I provide a fun it's like so extreme and
now we feed commercials bring it up
right here I would just peel the tip and
squish it all together like this and
then eat them in like fights
how long is I by the bus oh wow you're
really tough this is definitely right
but what's a foot I know that uses the
metric system it's not quite a foot take
this and then wrap it around a gusher
that was shouted man
I'm what Neyman halfway down oh my
favorite
oh yeah baby the cheese leaving any
snags means specifically our my absolute
favorite and it can't be the crackers
and cheese with a little red spreader
thing it's got to be the breadstick I
didn't like I always thought that the
breadsticks were too crunchy done like
that even as a kid I knew this is a
problem I just don't trust this there's
a whole like subculture of kids snacks
that we're all dumb face and these were
the like step-sister of dunkaroos I love
the cheese so much dye and it's like
dunking this much and then I just have
more crackers then this is coming from
my cow how processed is this just cheese
whatever it is cuz it's not cheese the
yellow stuff is great oh look the
package makes it look like it's yellow
but then when you take it away not that
yellow
it contains milk it's not the worst
thing there's sugar in this viral album
and enzyme cheese cultures I never been
a fan I'm still eating it though I think
I don't like it better as an adult that
I did as a kid it tastes better than it
smells
what is this this is genius I've never
been anything younger and been like man
sure wish I could drink this these were
like marketed towards this forty kids
you know like oh I gotta go to soccer
practice
let me grab it over why don't you eat
yogurt during soccer practice was soccer
practice
oh I swept it up and ride a skateboard I
don't like yogurt but I'll eat your
weird like this cuz it's more fun I
don't think you know girl stuff you
happen to I remember my mom bought us
these because you thought it was healthy
here's how I used to do it as soon as a
camera see
it says oh wow some sugary yogurt right
there doesn't really taste like
raspberry always have like the cheapy
version for all these snacks
it wasn't like go-gurt it was like going
as an adult it feels real weird that
even go here you can make your own
yogurt you could take some Activia put
in a ziploc bag I'm gonna Ziploc baggie
be like - I want the people on No come
up with you said we have to share so
great so I love a people love me that's
my favorite this I went down in school
is I got the kid with the pizza one was
the top dog yeah I'm a little explain
the pepperoni is the best take the
packet no no use the pepperoni slices
right we don't have to burn phones
[Music]
that's so sad in a real pizza the
cheetah blood toppings occasional a long
time coming I got it wasn't it's so
excited when the opportunity to eat
these I think the cheese could be better
the bottom is always the best part was
available people back it's a little
bland
there's no spice to it hold up oh great
yeah although I know this is what only
two crackers and one piece of meat and
crappy cheese I'm still good
any conversation about nineties kids
snacks typically start with gushers and
the commercials that you eat one it's
like explosion the dogs like surfing on
the juice and then you bite into it
nothing they don't gosh I knew there is
like a small amount of very viscous and
jelly inside loves everything about the
crusher so like weird shapes the dimmers
new like a mega gusher
no two textures give the one McIntosh
why are they already done the way to do
that I really remember
I would totally feed this to my kids I
try to make them you know healthier but
like you know has a little treat do
introduce the dude you're the snacks for
your childhood your daughter I'm very
surprised how much I still enjoy them
and it brought back nostalgia how
there's actually just fun like one of
these in the lunchbox yeah in moderation
in moderation it's fun to retry things
that you loved and remember we missed
all of this real
[Music]
you
[Music]